e
c'est par hélicoptère qu'alfred marie
jeanne et sa délégation gagne la
dominique le survol du nil des restes et
où tout n'est plus que ruines et
désolation
même le premier ministre fait partie des
sinistrés il a perdu sa maison
au pc de crise il reçoit alfred marie
jeanne
les deux hommes se connaissent bien ils
remercient à travers son ami les
martiniquais d'être à nouveau aux côtés
des dominicaines
pendant ce temps béni
aux manifestions solidarité
de la fenêtre wallu la rencontre voilà
ce qu'on aperçoit des maisons détruites
des familles désemparées
alfred marie-jeanne organise une réunion
avec des officiels dominicaine et des
pompiers de la martinique
c'est sympa bon père
tu es le bateau belle
lol si simplement peut-être que c'est
une idée sur ty a très rapidement pour
rien décidé il ôte la comédie à
disposition pour thématique le plus
urgent c'est d'apporter des vivres aux
personnes isolées qui ont été sinistrés
par l'ouragan maria
on a donc besoin également de tous les
hélicoptères possible pour acheminer la
nourriture à ces personnes des pompiers
martiniquais en première ligne pour
porter secours à la population
l'aide se met en place peu à peu
quarante tonnes d'eau ont déjà été
acheminés depuis fort-de-france la
demande et non évidemment nous on
demande forte des besoins de première
nécessité de l'eau de la nourriture des
moyens pour abriter les populations
parce que
tout est détruit et puis des demandes a
plus moyen terme de matériel de
de l'événement de matériel de
construction tout est à refaire quelques
heures sur place pour se rendre compte
des dégâts et des besoins dès
aujourd'hui jusqu'à mardi la ctm lance
une collecte en faveur des sinistrés de
la dominique
les dons sont reçues sur le site de la
collectivité à la pointe de jeanne